es la línea del frente en el sur de
jarquín aquí los ataques son diarios las
aldeas que recorren esta estepas
sobreviven gracias a la ayuda
humanitaria internacional que los
voluntarios consiguen traer cole que
está al cargo del convoy
de las aldeas a las que vamos a llevar
el kit de ayuda humanitaria están
destrozadas y no hay tiendas abiertas no
hay agua ni comida
y
van a intentar llegar hasta el límite
con las zonas ocupadas pero para ello es
esencial seguir protocolos de seguridad
en donde se reúnen con las autoridades
locales y emprenden su camino para
llegar a los territorios de primera
línea los voluntarios tienen que parar
en varias ocasiones para cambiar de
vehículos y poder acceder así a las
zonas más peligrosas que están ocupadas
por el ejército ruso pero la artillería
ha disparado contra uno de los destinos
de los voluntarios se ve lezca imposible
llegar hasta allí hay que cambiar de
plan dejarán la ayuda humanitaria en un
lugar seguro a 10 km de los bombardeos
la localización no se puede revelar no
es la primera vez que las tropas rusas
disparan a los camiones de ayuda
humanitaria
los drones rusos vigilan y si ven autos
desconocidos intentan destruirlos y
empiezan a disparar nos si es un local
el que recoge la ayuda y la lleva es más
probable que no le disparen por eso hoy
mañana los voluntarios solo podemos
llegar hasta aquí y dejar los productos
porque el ejército ruso está disparando
cada minuto
hasta este punto llegan también
ucranianos huyendo de las bombas galina
tiene 88 años y ha logrado escapar de la
cifra primera línea en esta guerra
hubo un misil que pasó por encima de mí
el sonido era ensordecedor y me desperté
en el suelo a cuatro metros de donde
estaba paseando
es muy duro vivíamos nueve personas en
una casa pequeña notebook
linkedin adquirió las tropas rusas
avanzan y presionan en su intento de
hacerse con el control de la región del
tomba si kharkiv la emergencia
humanitaria de los vecinos que están
atrapados en el frente y las zonas
ocupadas es extrema